en su primera entrevista importante
desde que fue elegido presidente
emmanuel macrón habló con la prensa
regional francesa el viernes prometiendo
que su segundo mandato como jefe de
estado no sería una repetición de los
últimos cinco años anunció la creación
de un nuevo consejo destinado a ayudar a
las reformas institucionales quiero
formar el consejo nacional de la
refundación con fuerzas políticas
económicas sociales y asociativas y con
cargos electos y ciudadanos que serán
elegidos al asad el portavoz del partido
de izquierda la francia en su misa lo
denominó consejo nacional de la
resistencia una opinión que es
compartida por otros en la política
francés el francés quien se va a tomar
esto en serio la creación de este
consejo nacional no es más que otro
truco un truco que pone en juego lo que
realmente hay que reconfigurar y no es
una democracia representativa ocurre a
bruce weber y si otro anuncio pensiones
las polémicas reformas se discutirán en
otoño y se pondrán en marcha en el
verano de 2023 el presidente francés
también se refirió a la candidatura del
izquierdista jean luc mélenchon a primer
ministro en caso de victoria de la nube
la nueva unión popular
elecciones legislativas ningún partido
político puede imponer el nombre de un
primer ministro al presidente el consejo
se formará tras las elecciones
legislativas que comienzan el domingo 12
de junio